l'attentât de la nuit dernière contre un
restaurant parisien a fait 30 blessés
n'a pas été revendiquée
et le bilan aurait pu être beaucoup plus
lourd toujours des questions sans
réponse à propos du raid des super
étendard français au liban le
gouvernement confirme que l'objectif a
bien été atteint
élection du nouveau président du parti
radical valoisien les radicaux de
l'opposition ne se rapprocheront pas des
radicaux de gauche
et puis coup d'envoi des manifestations
de soutien à l'école laïque elles
doivent se poursuivre jusqu'à la fin du
mois
aujourd'hui c'est dans la haute-loire
que les partisans de l'enseignement laïc
manifestants mesdames messieurs bonsoir
30 blessés dont un grièvement c'est le
bilan de l'attentât commis la nuit
dernière contre un restaurant parisien
l'orée du bois à la porte maillot et
l'on peut parler ce soir de véritables
miracles car le restaurant était plein
au moment de l'attentât 200 auvergnats
il tenait en effet un bang
et puis soudain dans des conditions
encore mal déterminées un ou deux hommes
ont jeté une bombe qui aurait dû
exploser à l'intérieur de la salle
heureusement un muret de briques arrêté
l'engin explosif évitant ainsi ce qui
aurait pu tourner au carnage
jean marc dubois on pouvait craindre le
pire en voyant ces images quand il hier
soir les blessés ont été transportés
vers l'hôpital ambroise paré de boulogne
malgré la violence de l'explosion il n'y
a eu que 30 blessés légers surtout
coupée par des éclats de verre
tremblay c'est qu'ils ont pu regagner
leur domicile vers 4 heures du matin
seule une personne a dû être hospitalisé
un vrai miracle car l'engin explosif
lancé au premier étage du restaurant
l'orée était destinée à tuer
jauzion juste compte du fait qu'il
rentrait en paix
tout le monde s'en fallait qu'ils
auraient été tirés
on était
- car aussitôt c'est la panique parmi
les 250 personnes qui dînent dans cette
salle de 150 auvergnats de paris réunie
pour leur banquet annuel des gens qui ne
comprennent pas pourquoi ils ont été la
cible de cet attentat
pourquoi eux la police non plus ne
comprend pas car 24 heures après
l'attentât n'ait toujours pas revendiqué
le propriétaire du restaurant cherche
aussi une explication mais hypothèses
sont les mêmes qu'hier au soir aucun
soupçon s'il ne ce n'est la conviction
que c'est véritablement un attentat
terroriste
il paraîtrait que ce serait nous qui
avons des difficultés financières et qui
peut-être aurions été les auteurs de cet
attentat
il faut être complètement débile pour
penser par les choses surtout à la
période qui précède les fêtes de fin
d'année où chacun dans notre activité
peut savoir que nous avons à faire à
face à un travail absolument énorme et
très important
alors je voudrais de là mais cette
précision je n'étais l'objet d'aucune
menace jeunes étaient l'objet d'aucun
raquette
je n'ai jamais envisagé de faire sauter
l'orée du bois pour mon propre compte ce
soir la salle dévasté par l'explosion a
été entièrement remise en état
plus de traces du drame comme pour
oublier pour effacer un attentat donc
personne pour l'instant on arrive à
comprendre la raison
confirmation iranienne aujourd'hui du
raid mené jeudi par les avions français
contre les milices islamiques installés
dans la région de baalbeck ou nord-est
du liban selon téhéran 14 iranien ce que
l'on appelle les gardiens de la
révolution aurait été tués au cours de
cette opération et l'imam khomeiny a
accusé la france de s'être déshonorée
par cette opération reste qu'à certain
mystère continue de planer sur les
résultats du raid des super étendard
français à l'origine il ya le flou des
informations fournies dans les premières
heures par l'état-major influent qui a
en principe était dissipée hier par le
ministre de la défense qui a donné des
précisions techniques sur le raid
il a notamment déterminer les
coordonnées exactes de l'objectif visé
et ce soir on y voit un peu plus clair
même si un certain nombre de détails
manquent encore je vous propose de faire
le point avec gérard ce bac qui connaît
bien la région de baalbeck où il était
encore il ya quelques mois
monsieur charles hernu indique comme
point de repère principal les six
colonnes du temple de jupiter les voici
l'objectif se situerait en face des
colonnes dans la direction sud sud est
vue générale de baalbeck prises toujours
à partir du temple de jupiter
on aperçoit alors parfaitement ce qui
pourrait être l'objectif des étendards
cette ancienne caserne de l'armée
libanaise avec ses murailles et ses deux
tours qui a été occupé récemment par les
gardiens de la révolution iraniens et
les combattants de l'organisation à
malices lamy à partir de ces données
nous avons établi une carte qui nous
vous permet de re préciser cet objectif
ici les colonnes de jupiter le sud sud
est indiqué par monsieur hernu plus une
indication supplémentaire 800 m à partir
de ces colonnes ici le centre de la
ville et les collines cheikh abdallah
qui aurait donc été la cible atteinte
par les super étendard
il faut tout de même remarquer car il
est très difficile malgré les données de
monsieur charles hernu d'être affirmatif
qu'il y à une autre caserne qui se
trouve elle aussi dans la direction sud
sud est
et qui est également occupée par les
gardiens de la révolution pour avoir une
certitude il faudra attendre des données
encore plus précises du ministère des
armées indications qui tarde à venir
oui et sur place les journalistes
occidentaux essayent depuis 48 heures de
parvenir jusqu'à cette région de
baalbeck
mais les risques sont grands et
apparemment personne ne souhaite leur
présence sur les lieux du raid
écoutez le témoignage de notre envoyé
spécial géré en guinée hier toute la
journée toute la nuit et ne me rendra
pas le bec
c'est impossible à 30 km de la ville les
syriens nous empêche de passer et nous
promène de casernes en caserne et j'ai
voulu aller voir le résultat du raid
français c'est parce que le taux de
survie
on ne sait plus très bien ce qui s'est
passé c'est d'iraniens à nous une chose
quatorze morts et des civils blessés les
français disent autre chose il y a une
énorme confusion sur les objectifs
atteints
sa seule conclusion ces conclusions il
ya c'est que sur le terrain libanais les
fait venir de ce rêve est complètement
détruit par cette impression de tout que
tout le monde ressent ici à beyrouth
allan poe là où est ce qu'on peut avoir
ce soir une idée sur ce qui s'est
vraiment passé à baalbeck
alors effectivement trois jours après ce
raid et c'est l'une des raisons
principales de la polémique le public
français ne dispose pas encore de preuve
formelle selon lesquels l'objectif a été
atteint par les avions super étendard
alors après avoir enquêté toute la
journée on m'a affirmé à plusieurs
sources que l'objectif a bel et bien été
détruits sans aucun doute possible en
effet les militaires français ont eu
trois semaines pour déterminer leur
cible la traiter comme l'on dit dans le
jargon des militaires et l'atteindre
cela n'a pas été très difficile
cependant un détail qui a son importance
au moment où les avions français eux qui
ont dû répondre ont attaqué les avions
français ont dû répondre à des tirs de
décès à au moment de pilonner la fameuse
caserne quant aux preuves de la réussite
de l'opération
elles sont à paris dit-on au ministère
de la défense et ce sont principalement
des films qui ont été tournés pendant
l'attaqué
grâce aux caméras embarquées sous les 1
des super étendard
ce qui est une procédure tout à fait
normale et on saura demain si le
gouvernement décide de les publier car
cette divulgation dépend d'abord d'une
décision politique au sommet et ensuite
de la qualité du matériel c'est à dire
des photos prises pendant le raid
voilà ce dont on dispose ce soir sans
oublier que dans cette affaire le
gouvernement français ne veut pas
compliquer les choses
diplomatiquement surtout l'opération a
été réussie dit on les soldats français
sont vengés
nous ne voulons pas en rajouter voilà en
tout cas ce qu'on dit du côté officiel
au liban toujours ce sont des combats
acharnés qui se déroule actuellement à
tripoli entre partisans et adversaires
de yasser arafat sans que l'on puisse
dire avec clarté qui al'avantage sur le
terrain nous vous parlons souvent de
ceux combattants loyalistes ou
dissidents c'est à dire ami ou ennemi de
yasser arafat et qui se battent pour
tenir ou reprendre les camps
palestiniens de la région
mais on parle moins souvent des
populations civiles qui vivent dans ces
camps car il s'agit bien de cordes de
réfugiés ainsi le compte de baddawi qui
file en jeu ces dernières semaines de
combats extrêmement violents
ces civils sont en première ligne et ce
sans gaz souvent eux qui payent le plus
gros tribut à la guerre du liban
le reportage de gérard minet et
jean-claude de la tremble sous un ciel
bas et sombre profitant d'une accalmie
les derniers habitants de beddaoui se
sont mobilisés
ils sont près de quinze mille
palestiniens à avoir quitté sedan en
emportant quelques appels
dans tripoli ils ont trouvé refuge dans
tous les bâtiments vides de la ville
dans cette école neuf familles se sont
entassés dans les petites salles de
cours
soulagé sinon rassurer c'est pour
beaucoup encore une fois un nouvel exode
depuis quinze ans j'ai toujours vécu
avec une valise à mes côtés j'ai quitté
la jordanie dont 171 après septembre
noir je me suis réfugiée à damas puis de
damas ça a été le sud liban à beyrouth
l'élégant au nord de tripoli et
aujourd'hui je suis ici en partant dans
cette école combien de temps
resteront-ils ici tous se posent la
question
aucune de ces familles ne croit la trêve
en attendant l'organisation de
libération de la palestine fournit la
nourriture de base et distribuer un peu
d'argent une situation que beaucoup
supportent de plus en plus difficile
ce que je veux c'est aller en palestine
mon mari est mort au sud liban je ne
veux plus entendre parler de caen je
veux aller en palestine avec mes enfants
si l'espoir de rentrer un jour à la
maison est restée vivace pour ces
familles la réalité aujourd'hui un autre
visage
celui de tous les réfugiés
et ce soir yasser arafat accuse les
syriens et les libyens de vouloir
détruire la ville de tripoli vers
laquelle ils avancent appuyé selon le
chef de l'ump par des chars et de
l'artillerie lourde
je vous rappelle que tripoli compte
quatre cent mille habitants et que seule
la deuxième ville du liban
voilà donc pour l'étranger en france ce
week-end politique était dominée par le
congrès du parti radical valoisien à
partie de l'opposition
les radicaux ont élu leur nouveau
président cette andré rossinot qui est
député maire de nancy et cette élection
représente un choix politique puisque
monsieur rossinot est opposé à tout
compromis entre son parti et le
mouvement des radicaux de gauche
un compromis dont il était question
pendant le congrès patricia jean michel
andré rossinot a gravi un à un tous les
échelons de la carrière politique
à 44 ans médecin fils d'instituteur déjà
élu député maire de nancy devient
président du parti radical
d'ores et déjà il en a rappelé la ligne
politique opposition sans ambiguïté au
pouvoir
les radicaux sont avant tout à mes
femmes responsables ils ne prendront pas
devant le pays le risque mortel pour la
france d'être ceux par lesquels la
presse socialisme serait retardé
bien au contraire
par sa participation totale au combat de
l'opposition unie par son influence au
sein de l'udf
le parti radical constituera le maillon
indispensable à la reconquête du pouvoir
rien n'est pas question donc le faire
comme le souhaitait olivier stirn une
alliance même à terme avec la gauche le
parti radical a dit andré rossinot
repoussera toutes les tentatives de
recentrage qui ne sont pour lui que
manoeuvre
c'est donc très clair ses alliés de lui
ds centriste et giscardien peuvent
respirer ce soir car leurs petits fours
radical leur restera fidèle georges
marchais parlait ce matin à nanterre un
discours attendu à la veille du sommet
pc ps prévues pour le 1er décembre le
secrétaire général du parti communiste
estime qu'un tel sommet est utile pour
faire le point alors que les députés en
sont à la moitié de leur mandat un
discours essentiellement centrée sur la
politique étrangère de la france
alep est l'occasion pour georges
marchais de rappeler les points d'accord
et de désaccord entre son parti et le
président de la république nous écoutons
monsieur marché il n'y a pas de
divergences entre les positions du
gouvernement celle définie par l'accord
de 1981 et lleno à propos de la peur
il en est de même à propos de
l'afghanistan
il en est de même à propos du liban il
en est de même à propos du châble il en
est de même à propos de grenade
tout cela est parfaitement clair en
définitive sur toutes ces questions
genevois à vrai dire qu'une seule
différence autres
le gouvernement et nous celles qui
portent sur la possibilité ou non de
comptabiliser la force de dissuasion
française dans l'inventaire complet des
forces en présence en europe
je ne vous fais pas de révélations cette
divergence est de notoriété publique et
je vais d'ailleurs y revenir mais on
admettra calais loin d'être de nature à
elle seule à faire éclater la coalition
gouvernementale
la semaine économique aura été marquée
par un véritable bombardement d'un 10
chiffres de l'emploi hausse des prix
pour le mois d'octobre progression du
dollar sur les places financières et
commerce extérieur mai en marge de ces
indices deux chiffres sont passée un peu
inaperçue et pourtant il prouve que les
français ont réduit leurs dépenses au
mois d'octobre un chiffre est
significatif
la consommation des ménages c'est-à-dire
notre consommation de tous les jours a
chuté de 6 % entre septembre et octobre
les explications de geneviève moll
cette baisse de la consommation apparaît
tout de même sélective pour les
personnes que nous avons interrogées à
paris dans une grande galerie marchande
vous êtes restreinte au cours de ces
derniers mois et semaines
mais ce qui manquerait ray loisirs
habillement oui
dans le domaine de la vie notamment et
de la lecture de la lecture cette
monnaie
j'essaye de les acheter d'occasion
seconde hurler dans les produits de
consommation type wifi télévision on est
un cas spécial bull moment dans ce monde
un peu voilà si tu oublies d'avoir pas
mal l'arabe et au niveau de
l'électroménager
ici on y est assez sensible en est
vraiment surpris ces témoignages vos
coupes les tendances indiquées par les
organismes officiels les français ont en
effet restreint leurs dépenses en
électroménager radiotélévision hi-fi
automobile chaussures droguerie loisirs
et vend logerie bijouterie des gens
achètent tout à leur dit on a eu beau
monde mais les gens achètent peut être
pour un pouvoir d'achat moindres
puisqu'il acheter
il dépense à face au mans 3 à 4000
francs l'année dernière ils dépensent
1000 milles francs cette année
faux ce qui est du textile et de
l'habillement et contrairement à ce que
font apparaître les témoignages les
statistiques les jeunes dans les gérer
housse c'est que comme pour l'horlogerie
bijouterie
les clients continuent d'acheter mais
moins et moins cher la tendance apparue
les mois précédents qui indiquaient une
préférence pour les vêtements de qualité
donc chers semblerait ainsi sa veste et
quant à l'alimentation on dit en baisse
elle reste un domaine préserver pour les
personnes que nous avons interrogées
sauf pour l'une d'entre elles vivent à
la campagne
il faudra attendre le mois prochain
celui des fêtes pour se voir si ce
tassement de la consommation des ménages
constitue un véritable reflet de la
rigueur et selon certains banquiers
cette baisse de la consommation
correspondrait à une époque que les
consommateurs ferait en prévision des
fêtes de fin d'année c'est peut-être une
explication
à noter la réponse de jacques khalid le
ministre de l'emploi après les
déclarations d'andré bergeron qui
mettait en cause y lire les chiffres de
l'emploi publiés par le ministère du
travail
j'appartiens à un gouvernement qui ne
truque pas qu'il ne magouille pas a
déclaré monsieur khalid qui était
l'invité du grand jury rtl le monde
je vous propose maintenant de faire
connaissance avec la petite nouvelle de
la régie renault
enfin quand je dis petit c'est une image
puisque la r25 c'est son nom doit
prendre la relève des modèles et revint
et airtran on devrait commencer à la
voir rouler sur les routes à partir du
mois de mars prochain pour ce nouveau
modèle l'effort a été porté sur la
qualité de la fabrication
et pour ça des bureaux d'études de la
régie ont fait appel à des méthodes qui
ne sont pas sans rappeler ce qui se
passe au japon
le reportage de jean claude roinot
avant première sur la r 25 pour les 9600
travailleurs de sandouville qui la
découvrent par petits groupes
c'est normal ce sont eux qui vont la
fabrique mais c'est inhabituel la régie
avant de séduire le client veut
convaincre ses ouvriers sur le thème la
qualité du haut de gamme
c'est d'abord les concurrentes de la r25
renault les montres à son personnel
ici une bmw 524 chacun est invité à
comparer objectif améliorer le produit
maison de diesel dire elle est moins bon
a élevé six ans c'est aussi l'objectif
de la mini-chaîne expérimentale où sont
formés 1300 monteur avec l'aide d'un
système vidéo
il s'agit d'être prêt en mars quand la
r25 sera commercialisée la montée en
cadence sera rapide 600 voitures par
jour
l'enjeu pour la r25 c'est le créneau du
haut de gamme 16% du marché européen
soit 1 million 600 mille véhicules l'an
dernier
actuellement dans cette catégorie 5 %
seulement des véhicules sont des renaud
herbin et r30
l'objectif de la régie avec la r25 est
d'atteindre 9 % de ce marché fin 84 le
pari est ambitieux d'autant que les
constructeurs français n'ont jamais
vraiment réussi avec les grandes
routières
larmes de la régie c'est la r25 qui sera
proposé avec cinq moteurs du 2 litres
essence au v6 à injection deux sortes de
transmission mécanique à 5 rapports ou
automatique à trois rapports trois
sortes d'équipements selon les modèles
avec ordinateur de bord et synthèse de
la parole
les prix sont encore inconnues mais on
peut raisonnablement avancé une
fourchette de 80 milles à 100 même ivre
bien
bon
début des manifestations cet après-midi
du comité national d'action laïque les
partisans de l'école publique avait
choisi la ville d'yssingeaux pour leur
première manifestation qui a regroupé
entre vingt et trente cinq mille
personnes
thème du défilé le développement la
transformation et l'unification laïque
du système éducatif la ville
d'yssingeaux avait été choisi car c'est
un fief de l'enseignement catholique
puisqu'on compte dans cet arrondissement
cette vie c'est qu'ils sont tous
professionnels
monsieur savary a réaffirmé lors du vote
du budget de l'éducation qu'il
souhaitait voir s'ouvrir rapidement des
négociations avec les responsables de
l'enseignement public et privé des
négociations qui promettent déjà d'être
très difficile pourtant au delà des
discussions qui vont avoir lieu
il y a la situation sur le terrain ce
qui ne va pas là aussi sans poser un
certain nombre de problèmes
c'est ce qu'ont pu voir estelle gouzy et
bernard brengues à mons en baroeul dans
la banlieue lilloise sur la place jean
xxiii la place de l'église
les bâtiments de l'institution
catholique saint-honoré la treille font
face aux écoles publiques sévigné
guynemer entre elles ce n'est pas la
guerre juste l'indifférence en 1977 la
commune passe à gauche et le jeune maire
socialiste lui-même enseignants décident
d'engager le dialogue
on avait un problème concret par réseau
celui de la construction d'une salle de
sport à mons en baroeul
c'est vrai qu'on l'a situé dans une
démarche intellectuelle plus général qui
est celui du rapprochement de
l'enseignement public et l'enseignement
privé
actuellement les enfants du vieux mans
ce doivent marcher 20 bonnes minutes
pour se rendre à la cantine
la municipalité propose à l'enseignement
catholique à marcher leur terrain contre
une école neuve la jouissance partage
avec l'école publique d'une salle de
sport et d'une cantine construite sur
place l'école privée lui ni d'un bail de
50 ans devient locataire de la ville
loyers payés d'avancé par le prix des
terrains en contrepartie l'école privée
sera gratuite
actuellement les parents versent en
moyenne 60 francs par mois proposition
alléchante pour le diocèse et pourtant
il est évident qu'au départ nous avons
été un peu surpris par cette proposition
et nous ne savions pas très bien comment
comment avancer comment négocier en fait
vous messieurs un peu bien sûr qu est ce
que vous craignez et bien nous craignons
surtout peut-être de ne plus pouvoir
avoir enfin exercer notre enseignement
est librement et nous pensions que si
nous n'étions plus propriétaire des
écoles peut-être y avait-il davantage de
possibilités pour le propriétaire de
mettre un entrave une entrave à notre
liberté
l'enseignement catholique croate au
libéralisme du maire et accepte la
proposition une seule garantie exigée
pouvoir à tout moment racheter son école
reste à convaincre les tenants des deux
écoles publiques instituteur et
directeur s'opposent au projet d'abord
en tant que laïc c'est quelque chose qui
me semble un peu curieux que l'on donne
cette école à une privée et surtout nous
n'attendions pas ça de ma seule rolf
mehr socialiste certains intégristes de
la laïcité en reste la vieille idée au
vieux débat fonds publics écoles privées
nous ce qu'on voit c'est qu'il va y
avoir des fonds publics pour s'occuper
des enfants
deux manches dont les parents ont choisi
un projet pédagogique particulier ce que
nous respectons tout à fait et qui situe
dans cette perspective de rapprochement
des deux écoles demain tout ça ça sera
ensemble dans un même service public où
il y aura une liberté d'enseignement y
aura un projet pédagogique ici avec
telle dimension spirituelle là avec tel
autre dimension pédagogique
mais tout ça c'est les enfance et les
enfants de la république l'essentiel
c'est de les rassembler
malgré des réticences dans les deux
camps le projet du maire est finalement
adoptée après un vote favorable des
parents d'élèves du public et du privé
alors des négociations au plan national
la grande première de mons en baroeul
donne le ton et pourrait bien servir
d'exemple oui le débat n'est pas près
d'en finir par man au chapitre des faits
divers les suites de la fusillade au
cours de laquelle quatre femmes ont été
blessées vendredi après une querelle
d'automobilistes
les deux agresseurs ont été identifiés
par la police et l'un d'eux s'est
constitué prisonnier
alors on connaissait mal les détails de
l'altercation qui devait aboutir à ce
drame des parents d'une des victimes
raconte l'histoire
l'homme qui a blessé quatre jeunes
femmes vendredi soir rue des petites
écuries est un ressortissant turc arrivé
depuis 4 jours seulement à paris le
chauffeur de la bmw qu'il conduisait la
voiture d'où est sorti le tireur fou
avait quitté les lieux avant le
mitraillage
il s'est présenté spontanément à la
police et a été mis hors de cause
il s'est déclaré menacés par ce
compatriote violent rencontrer dans un
centre d'accueil de réfugiés turc à
marseille et qui dès son arrivée dans le
quartier des petites écuries avaient
semé la panique dans les cafés en
symbolisant les jours des quatre jeunes
femmes ne sont pas en danger latent de
l'une d'entre elle se fit pagès raconte
t-elle sont descendus de leur voiture
ils se sont aggravées sur le trottoir
ils ont commencé à aller frapper
et puis l'un a sorti son revolver et à
tiré successivement sans les cadres
le jeune fille à l'hôpital comme ses
amis est encore sous le choc de
l'incroyable incident elle n'a pas l'air
trop mal elle était encore un peu
traumatisé par par tout ce qui vient
d'arriver
là elle a un oeil au beurre noir ils les
ont battus avant de leur tirer dessus
elles sont les soeurs est encore plus
touchée qu'elle l'a une balle qui lui a
traversé la jambe et qui ressortit
heureusement mais enfin ils et elles
souffrent beaucoup b mais ça n'est pas
trop trop trop gras elle est jeune elle
passe en belgique 10 paix le conducteur
de la voiture est en garde à vue sous la
protection de la police
et tout a été mis en oeuvre pour arrêter
le plus vite possible
le tireur fou fait divers toujours avec
l'enlèvement d'une rice bijoutière
italienne qui est enlevé près de rome
avec l'un de ses fils il s'agit de
madame bulgarie qui est l'une des
copropriétaires de la prestigieuse
bijouterie bulgarie l'un de ses cousins
gianni avaient déjà été enlevées en 75
libéré quelques mois plus tard après le
versement d'une rançon de plus d'un
milliard de lires
et puis il y avait un tiercé aujourd'hui
à auteuil je vous laisse découvrir les
résultats sur votre petit écran il
fallait jouer le 2 le 5 et le 4 ce qui
rapporte dans l'ordre pour 5 francs 382
francs 50 centimes et dans un ordre
différent toujours pour 564 france ce
qui n'est pas cher payé
la météo avec baugé de simonetta voilà
vous connaissez sûrement la dînette que
l'on pose souvent aux enfants
quel est le plus lourd un kilo de plus -
kilos de plomb eh bien je reprends cette
devinette amant compte à une température
donnée que les le plus froid un froid
sec ou un froid humide est évident que
souvent nous supportons mal d'humidité
aussi demain aurons-nous la pression
d'avoir plus froid et pourtant je vous
rassure ce ne sera qu'une sensation car
le thermomètre restera stable par
rapport au jour d'hui
regardez la photo satellite et regardez
surtout surtout cette formidable
dépression très creuse très profond
c'est elle qui a donné les pluies
diluviennes sur le portugal vendredi
soir nous nous sommes bien d'y indien
malaria mais nous en subissons tout de
même des effets sur le sud du pays
des effets bien sûr très atténué en
faire regarder honore ses tâches plus
clair ce sont des nuages qui descend des
îles britanniques et qui vont descendre
encore plus à l'intérieur du pays tout
cela nous donne comme tendance sur la
carte de demain temps couvert donc avec
des averses de l'aquitaine littoral
méditerranéen et à la corse
des nuages également mais beaucoup moins
méchant du nord à la presqu'île du
cotentin et jusqu'aux alpes du nord
ils donneront des toutes petites pluies
des ondes et surtout sur les frontières
de l'efs et peut-être même de la neige
sur le relief
enfin de la bretagne à la vallée du
rhône après dissipation du brouillard
matinal ce sera du beau temps le
baromètre reste stade même chose donc je
vous disais pour le thermomètre il va
geler cette nuit très fort sûrement
jusqu'à -8 crée surtout sur les parties
centrales
et puis demain dans l'après midi nous
arriverons de 4° à 10 degrés sur la
moitié nord et de 6 à 16 degrés sur la
moitié sud
demain nous ferons le lundi 21 novembre
le soleil se lèvera à 8h09 il se
couchera 17h03 ce sera une célébration
religieuse la présentation de marie très
bien ce journal va se refermer vous avez
rendez-vous à 22h50 avec hervé claude
pour la dernière édition et un débat sur
la psychanalyse et le cinéma
à propos de la sortie du film de maurice
pialat à nos amours
demain à 12h45 noël mamère et à 20h vous
retrouverai christine ockrent qui sera
dans ce fauteuil
mais avant de nous quitter terminons ce
journal par une image cela se passait
cet après midi ap
gahtan bois de boulogne de la
reconstitution historique du premier
volume 1 il y a deux cent ans le 21
novembre 1783 deux hommes pilâtre de
rozier et le marquis d'arlempdes
s'envolait à bord d'une montgolfière
identique à celle ci partie de la muette
et traversèrent le paris de l'époque
pour atterrir à la butte-aux-cailles
actuellement portés détails
dix jours plus tard le 1er décembre 1783
s'est faite autour de charlie et robert
d'effectuer le premier vol à bord d'un
ballon à gaz dont la réplique a été
reconstituée pour le musée de l'air je
vous souhaite une excellente soirée sur
antenne 2
1 me
à